earlier this week dragon ball got some
exciting news with the very first teaser
trailer for the new dragon ball super
movie some people were excited some were
upset because of the cgi and yet
all i could think about this week was
this
that's right this week i was reading
through some of the best original dragon
ball has to offer and
no i'm not talking about raditz through
dimajin buu i'm talking about the
original arcs that comprise the
beginning of this story or as i like to
affectionately refer to it as
oh my god this is like forty percent of
the freaking story how has no one seen
this
it's amazing but yes uh you heard me
right most people haven't seen about
forty percent of the story the red
ribbon army has returned down
he saw z stretching from the pilaf saga
all the way through to piccolo jr it's
easily one of the most
underrated stories in all of manga and
anime that i know of and with the
majority of people now focusing on the
latest transformations chapters and
trailers for the upcoming movie i
figured it should be my responsibility
to show people where this series came
from and why it's widely considered by
those that have read it
some of the absolute best material the
series has to offer
that's right i'm talking funny i'm
talking action-packed
i'm talking hey mom go to the store to
get some tissues because goku's making
me cry
and you know what they didn't need to
create a multiverse tournament or make
constant callbacks to itself
to get a reaction from its audiences
either this is an immortal story with
legacy
action comedy and sadness and quite
simply
this original tale set the foundation
for the story that will go on to capture
the hearts and minds of
millions across the world for decades to
come which
is why i'm so nervous writing this video
this is a cultural touchstone of a story
and i want to do it justice
so what are we waiting for i'm totally
not mark and this is my review of akira
toriyama's
underrated and undefeated dragon ball
truth be told i'm actually unreasonably
excited to get into this with all of you
today
so let's dive into the very first saga
that catapult the dragon ball into
japanese pop culture
i'm talking about the 23 chapter long
peel off saga
yes
[Music]
god it feels so strange but amazing to
be back in this world with new eyes
after having spent the last decade
learning about storytelling one of the
first things that immediately became
apparent to me was how effective
toriyama was at characterization
particularly with both goku and bulma
right off the bat utilizing paneling
framing and dialogue to push this
aspect of his story you can absolutely
tell that this isn't his first manga
either
while the story is very simple it is so
for specific
measured reasons the first chapter kicks
off our story with the famous
and effective first meeting of goku and
his soon to be lifelong friend
bulma and i call this scene effective
because while toriyama has made plenty
of questionable writing decisions
throughout his long career
i don't believe he could have handled
this first chapter any better
the priority of the first chapter
typically is to introduce us to
and bond us with the main characters of
the arc and immediately toriyama
highlights how these two characters he
created
are exact opposites of each other goku
is physically strong but innocent and
naive
bulma is physically weak in comparison
but is much more experienced and on
another intellectual level to goku
altogether with their first decisions
made in the story not wasting any time
in their characterization acting as a
window into who these people really are
goku is inquisitive with some shockingly
friendly
and naivety thrown into the mix his
first action is to attack and use his
brawn to overcome the obstacle
all the while bulma after reflexively
going for her gun a mechanical
enhancement her first thought is to try
and manipulate goku into handing over
his dragon ball and to help her on her
quest
this is our starting point and it tells
us so so much about who these characters
are and what possibilities might lie
ahead in their story together
[Music]
furthermore i was delighted to see
toriyama's brilliant use of paneling
used to reinforce this avenue of
characterization
more traditionally i really appreciate
how toriyama uses his layouts to build
anticipation for a page turn this
is a minor example and i'll show more as
the stakes rise over the course of the
story but
this page with goku overlooking a cliff
it's a tall
and narrow panel with goku pictured
quite small atop
of it and it's given this real estate to
tell us quite simply that this cliff is
extremely tall and on that same page
goku is shown not to care about that as
he jumps down with ease
communicating that this isn't a normal
everyday boy it's a small choice but it
sure as hell beats someone lecturing to
us
that he's some freakishly strong kid and
on the topic of visuals
the first chapter has one of my favorite
panels in
all of the story this one this image on
its own to me
acts as a microcosm of what goku will do
in the story moving forward his outward
appearance will make someone think one
thing and then they will quickly be
taken off guard by something they did
not expect
from him bulma up until this point and
even on this very panel's page
has been contemplating and formulating a
plan to exploit goku she's seen it all
before and she feels like she knows
exactly what's coming
and as goku proceeds into his modest
living quarters bulma doesn't find
someone living there with him she
doesn't find anything she might be
expecting
instead she sees a small boy earnestly
praying before a totem representing his
deceased
grandpa gohan the four-star ball i love
this image
bulma does continue to try and exploit
goku's understanding and innocent nature
for her benefit
but this panel marks the moment she
starts to build some sort of bond with
the character moving on from that
opening i think it's important to point
out that this arc is unlike any other
dragon ball arc that will come
after it it's clear that toriyama went
into this with a specific vision one
that was inspired largely by the chinese
story journey to the west with
characters like
goku oolong and yamcha among others
encountering fantastical beings
clearly inspired by the aforementioned
story and across these opening 23
chapters goku and bulma travel across
the globe in search of these magical
orbs
called dragon balls title drop all in an
effort so that bulma can make a wish for
a
perfect boyfriend you heard me right she
wants to wish for a boyfriend
oh how the times have changed you might
be saying in pursuing these orbs
they meet oolong who was this weird
shape-shifting pervert
we meet yamcha and poor as they attempt
to rob goku and ko in the desert as well
as a litany of bizarre and crazy
characters like boss rabbit an
individual in charge of a gang of rabid
cosplaying thugs that also possesses the
power to turn individuals like bulma
into a carrot this first arc is off the
wall bonkers bouncing from iconic scenes
to comedic scenes to outright strange
scenes
but what ties them all together is the
strong focus on comedy
that this first arc primarily basks in
the original dragon ball particularly
this first saga is very comedy focused
with entire scenarios sometimes being
built around a single joke
and these jokes have layers to them not
layers of any intellectual complexity
definitely not but
layers of loose narrative complexity and
i mean that for instance
despite many of you not having seen this
part of the story you may have seen
this particular scene
all right so this one gag highlighting
the innocence of goku in this crazy
situation has the knock-on effect
whereby it informs and drives the plot
through
a secondary gag with roshi later on
convincing him to hand over his dragon
ball
later again after bulma loses the
capsules with her clothes and supplies
she has to borrow a dumb outfit from
oolong
it's a shallow gag but funnily enough it
informs much of the humor behind the
hijinks that takes place in the village
with boss rabbit running the roost
this town they wander into has been
terrorized by this gang that dresses up
as rabbits and when the townsfolk start
to give bulma a wide berth
because of what she's wearing she
assumes the only possible conclusion is
that they're intimidated by her beauty
all of these scenarios the stuff with
goku roshi oolong and eventually boss
rabbit
are all examples of comedic moments that
only work when we know the characters
involved
bulma's scaring people while dressed as
a playboy bunny is a funny visual on its
own
but it's even more funny when you know
that this was the only
outfit that oolong had extra in his car
and it's made even funnier again
when you realize that bulma is so
egotistical that she convinced herself
that it made
perfect sense that people were treating
her this way because
she was so beautiful now is it stupid
and borderline creepy given bulma's age
and the material
and the age of the mangaka drawing it
yeah definitely maybe
but it's still made in lighthearted fun
and layered through character
narratively pushing the story forward
people nowadays love to take dragon ball
very seriously whether it be its theme
story or messaging and this story no
doubt means a lot to tons and tons of
different people across the world but at
the end of the day
this story particularly this material in
the arc was written
as a comedy first and foremost not to be
taken very seriously at all
i mean there's an entire page with the
peel off gang dedicated to talking about
and making meta jokes concerning
toriyama's prior work in dr slump that
and
also goku sent boss rabbit to the moon
using his nyobo or power pole or
whatever you want to call it
makes you wonder what happened to him
when
yeah all right so before i dive into my
absolute favorite aspect of this first
arc i think i should rattle off some of
the iconic scenes and honorable mentions
i have also
i loved how cute and innocent both goku
and chichi's first encounter was
and i love how the way their dialogue
was written accentuates their rural
backgrounds and sensibilities
not only by creating some endearing
character writing but forcing us as
readers to see similarities between the
two of them
on a foundational fundamental level as
goku's obliviousness clashes with
chi-chi's traditional ideal
the dynamic is honestly perfect from a
lower standpoint it also acts as the
first place we see goku's tail acting as
a significant weak spot in the series
moving on the first kamehameha in the
series is absolutely top tier
these big page spreads from akira
toriyama absolutely
hit different compared to so many other
mangaka both past and present to me
furthermore in addition to this scene's
stunning visuals we get to see goku
nail the kamehameha almost immediately
after seeing roshi use it once
this marks the moment roshi saw goku as
a special prospect
going as far as to offer him training
once he's ready oh my god
is that foreshadowing i think it is
alright now time for my favorite part of
the first arc
while i enjoyed the first ark story in a
light-hearted passive fashion up until
this point
it wasn't until this arc's climax that
dragon ball became what i recognized as
dragon ball and while it's still not in
its final form just yet
i'll get to that in the next arc it
still showed signs of heading in that
direction
this change in narrative direction
wasn't a mistake either and there's some
really interesting
behind-the-scenes info regarding how
toriyama and his editor at the time
torishima
saw this issue that i am totally going
to talk about in like two minutes
narratively however i think this is the
ark's strongest section
there's a wonderful combination of plot
threads that create a beautiful martini
of circumstance
particularly during this instance where
pilaf has stolen all of the dragon balls
they collected and trapped them in this
chamber with the ceiling exposed to the
sky
readying them to be baked under the hot
morning sun once it eventually rose
sitting there while waiting for death
they begin chatting about the moon's
beauty until goku starts talking about
his experience
with the moon and in doing so he begins
telling them a story of a monster his
grandpa warned him about that comes out
during
a full moon having been exposed to the
otherworldly strength of goku his
heightened senses and
the sudden death of his grandpa gohan
this is when the characters sharing the
chamber with him as well as us at home
start to understand what tragic event
transpired that day
[Music]
it's superbly subtle and effective
particularly for a manga that
prioritizes gags and action above this
sort of character-rich experience
and it's this sort of dedication to
slowly invading the world building it up
over time that gave dragon ball this
mystical magic and fun feel
during this period as well as moving
forward designing characters that are
exact opposites of each other and
transporting them through this adventure
not with any specific goal in mind
necessarily but to see how this
experience
impacts them personally in the case of
goku we learn all of this new
information about him and in the case of
bulma she gained some new friends and
maybe more
by the way i love this page where bulma
and yamcha both recognize that they were
exactly what each other were looking for
all along the page layout is great and
visually communicates what it needs to
in a childish and endearing manner you
know
after oolong wishes for panties which is
another great moment and paige i guess
however what many of you might not know
is that during this time
the ending portion of the pilaf saga
sales for dragon ball dipped noticeably
or experienced a lull according to
kazuhiko torishima dragon ball's editor
that worked alongside toriyama and to
remedy this apparently torashima
turned to study fists of the north star
the most popular manga at the time
and after reading it he identified three
areas where dragon ball could improve
moving forward
number one the first thing they did was
cut down the number of characters
throughout the first arc toriyama had
introduced a large number of new
characters like goku bulma oolong yamcha
poor roshi turtle ox king
chichi mai shu pilof as well as the
numerous other villains they encountered
along the way
and so when moving into the next arc of
the story together they decided to have
a much smaller more focused cast
centered around goku
roshi and the newly introduced krillin
the second thing they wanted to focus on
was to increase the coolness factor
which also flows naturally into the
third thing they wanted to change
they wanted to break the established
convention of the series part of the
reason sales declined torashima
suspected was due to the formula that
appeared in the first arc
once the genie was out of the bottle or
in this case dragon fans got the
impression that they knew what direction
the series would go in and so the
tournament saga was born
ushering in a new era of manga and in
turn establishing dragon ball
as he forced to be reckoned with the
rise of dragon ball
had begun
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
training with roshi to say that this arc
influenced other popular series yet to
come would be
an understatement after having taken on
the philosophy of less is more from
fists of the north star
and a quick trip abroad to look at some
ruins in ancient architecture akira
toriyama was primed to inject dragon
ball with the same vigor
passion and action it would become
famous for in the not so distant future
and it all starts with this little boy
asking this old perverted man
to train him like the first arkham joy
this one also has a strong focus on the
more lighthearted aspects of the series
particularly through new characters and
their introductions
instead of telling us what sort of
people these characters are clunkily the
vehicle of comedy helps us
understand them more for instance soon
after goku arrives on the island and
fails to locate a woman for roshi
krillin makes his grand entrance onto
the scene
[Music]
[Applause]
he comes across as a more self-centered
individual initially thanks to a certain
comedic moment courtesy of goku's cloud
in addition to that another character we
get to know in this arc is that of lunch
or
launch in the dub she's a character
taylor made for early dragon ball with
her sneezing offering up tons of comedic
hijinks but my favorite joke from her
more subdued innocent side comes by way
of roshi's desperate persuasion attempt
to make her wear
a specific uniform after coming out
dressed in what she was given
lunch asks if maybe the packages got
mixed up we then hard cut to the three
guys all peddling this same charade
wearing the same
uniform and in response to this roshi
humbly requests that she
please don't insult the traditional
uniform of the kame school as he learns
lecherously towards her flanked by a
visibly confused goku that's taking all
of this
a little too seriously much the same way
a strong emphasis was placed on the
differences between goku and bulma early
on
krillin acts in the first half of this
arc as the foil to goku with a strong
distinction made between them almost
immediately firstly through his failure
to board the magical cloud but also his
less than heroic saving of lunch
and most importantly through the
training he received from roshian
speaking of which
[Music]
i loved the training of krillin and goku
their dynamic is pitch perfect for what
this arc is calling for and acts as a
strong first indication
of the insecure antagonistic character
type that will become more and more
commonplace around goku moving forward
bouncing well off of his innocent and
honest persona roshi's introductory
challenge the footrace is a terrific
example of why this character type and
why this version of krillin is
entertaining and effective
taking turns krillin explodes off the
mark first completing the 100 meter dash
in a little over 10 seconds
an impressive effort no matter who you
are however what makes this a great
opportunity for characterization is what
toriyama has given these characters to
say to each other in response to their
respective efforts with krillin this
gave us a great indication as to where
his ideals and goals
lie basking in the impressive time he
said gloating about it both to goku
roshi and even internally to himself
whereas with goku once he sets an even
faster time
he doesn't gloat instead his first
instinct is to genuinely ask if that was
fast
in the next challenge when it came to
retrieving the rock roshi through
krillin and goku are first of all faced
with descending a certain cliff face
however we know from the first chapter
that this is no issue for goku and
watching as surprise descends over
krillin's face
is the first instance of another trick
soon to become commonplace in the dragon
ball story
this is a narrative tool called dramatic
irony we know what goku is capable of
but new characters like krillin in this
instance
don't it is fun and somewhat cathartic
at this point but later this same
technique will be used to effectively
depict goku as a monstrous threat to the
ignorant adversaries of the future
furthermore this whole challenge is a
brilliantly constructed scene
narratively
with more moving parts than you might
actually anticipate from an early dragon
ball story krillin knowing full well
that there are tons of people living on
this island that they've moved to for
training instead of finding the rock
that roshi threw in a race with someone
he knows he'll lose against
krillin decides to try to borrow a
marker and find a similar looking rock
to fake his successful retrieval roshi
does throw the rock back into his face
but it's a good idea that
involves thinking outside of the box
krillin honestly impressed me here but
he's also demonstrating a character flaw
that will always mean goku will be
better than him if he doesn't shake this
sensibility despite this admittedly
clever
idea however he's forced to search in
earnest for the rock but to no success
once again
goku finds it however through some more
underhanded and clever use of strategy
he out-thinks goku and distracts him
with a fake rock
this whole interaction challenge was a
fun little exchange that highlights
goku's weak spots also a weak spot he'll
have for a very very long time in some
shape or form
he trusts his opponents too much but
that's enough of these warm-ups
it's time for some serious roshi
training
[Music]
one does not strive for victory over an
opponent one strives to avoid defeat by
one's own self
in the beginning of this final set of
trials roshi announces to the two young
boys that in eight short months
they will be participating in the
tenkaichi budokai a world martial arts
tournament and what makes this sequence
interesting for me at least isn't
exclusively how powerful these two stand
to become or the amazing techniques they
will learn while training under roshi
in fact they don't really learn any
techniques at all beyond what they
already arrived with
instead there's a strong focus on
philosophy
through the intense manual labor
education and effort put in over these
months
fans of dragon ball super might
recognize a particular quote
sitting in a hammock alongside the first
pupils he's taken on in a very very long
time
he tells them to move well study well
play well
eat well rest well that is the turtle
master way
there are a number of brilliant quotes
from this training mini arc but
my favorite is the one i started this
section with one does not strive for
victory over an opponent one strives to
avoid defeat by one's own self
it summarizes succinctly what i love
about this story and roshi's teachings
particularly he talks about using the
power acquired through this practice for
the betterment and protection of others
to never strive with the single-minded
view of winning against your opponent
but to instead not fall into the
pitfalls such elusive thinking will lead
you down
to always look past that and to always
strive to better yourself regardless of
the immediate goal or outcomes you face
it's a powerful and resilient philosophy
that toriyama has baked into the
foundation of this franchise
and a perfect piece of serious and
useful philosophy amidst the silliness
of this action-adventure comic
the tenkaichi budokai this is the first
tournament in the dragon ball series
however for those of you that know this
series well
you'll know that this isn't by any means
the last not in any stretch of the
imagination the broader dragon ball
story these days is somewhat synonymous
with tournament arcs of various shapes
and sizes whether they be these
tenkaichi budokai more intimate affairs
like with baba later on in the story the
cell games are even to varying degrees
in the wider universe
dragon balls roots are very much in
these tournament arcs it helped to
popularize and it started
all here and it starts with a bang on
the back of that important philosophy
lesson is the two boys very
first test in the big bad world and the
test isn't necessarily the tournament
itself which honestly was kind of
interesting the significance this
tournament represents is once more
embedded in the philosophy that to truly
be a master of martial arts you need to
always be learning and improving and if
either goku
or krillin were to win this tournament
and be crowned strongest under the
heavens
they might not learn that lesson and
given what roshi has seen them do
during their training he needs to come
up with a solution to this potential
problem
fast now when you say tournament arc a
surface level analysis of that statement
might lead you to believe that this
setting
only offers fights and while it does
offer those in abundance
it's more than anything else a simple
backdrop that allows the story
and characters to shine brighter due to
the various scenarios it can readily
provide
similar to the setting of a high school
tournaments are a familiar and easy to
understand setting for readers these
settings create natural scenarios for
central or relevant characters to come
into conflict with each other
and in the case of the shonen action
genre a tournament arc is tailor-made
for that sort of story as readers this
is our first time encountering a world
tournament in the universe of dragon
ball
much the same way this is krillin and
goku's first time and these qualifying
rounds in the tournament
for the eight main tournament spots
available act also as the bridging of
any gap there might exist between
krillin and the audience
a character that was once an antagonist
to our hero goku is now much closer to
the endearing self-conscious and
apprehensive character we're familiar
with today in addition to him acting
early on as the audience's surrogate in
this two being his first world
tournament
asking all the sort of questions we as
readers would ask he too is confronted
by the group he fled from
one that exhibits all the
characteristics he had towards the
beginning of this arc
in other words we're made aware of the
people who made krillin the person he
was
they are slimy cruel and they are
fighting krillin
in the qualifiers
yeah that felt good goodbye old krillin
hello bold new world
and really these qualifiers here are all
about catharsis and context
it allows us as an audience the
opportunity to take stock of how capable
these boys are after the grueling and
laborious training they underwent for
the better part of a year against all of
these strongest fighters in the world
with little effort goku and krillin
qualify along with a returning
short-haired yamcha for the final eight
next up are the quarter-finals as it
pertains to this tournament's various
heats
the quarterfinals are probably the ones
with the greatest emphasis on comedy and
really for me
are the weakest of the arc now that's
not to say that i didn't have fun
reading this section or that it doesn't
have strong moments it most definitely
does like yamcha versus jackie chan for
instance but
fights like bacterium versus krillin and
goku vs giron
are very clearly there to primarily dish
out some comedic relief which is fine
but i would have liked a little more
drama personally but yeah krillin's
first serious outing as i said is
against an apparently formidable
adversary called bacterium
a giant man whose edge comes from his
refusal to ever bathe
there's some great paneling by toriyama
here that will become more commonplace
as we press forward too
with the contrast emphasized between the
tiny hero and the giant bully right
before he's defeated with that said the
fight comes to a close thanks to goku
reminding krillin that he doesn't have a
nose and therefore
can't smell him
[Music]
[Applause]
next up is yamcha vs jackie chun and it
is my favorite of the fights from this
section
it's here we're made aware that roshi
under an alias and disguise has entered
himself into the tournament to prevent
the two boys from winning and losing
their motivation for improvement
told from the point of view of yamcha we
follow him as he's totally overpowered
by the older martial artist in jackie
chung
there's some great panel work but it's
probably the shortest fight in all of
these main contests
[Applause]
namu vs ram fan is a strange one as a
reader you'd be forgiven for wondering
why we're dedicating time to this
conflict
it doesn't involve any character we've
been introduced to and so toriyama
offered this up as an opportunity to not
necessarily focus on namu though he does
sort of but to instead leverage his
noble intentions that we do learn about
him
to build up roshi's character instead
through this number character we learn
how much roshi may very well be capable
of as he uses his
mysterious abilities to read namu's mind
and in addition to that we learn of the
horrible circumstances after befalling
his village
waiting on him to return with water
after he wins the tournament prize money
his goal is to save his village and that
motivation despite randfan's best effort
was enough to help him
claim the victory over here
goku vs kiran is the last fight before
the semis and to be honest this was the
fight i liked the least in this section
it's still perfectly fine but there's a
lot of strange goings-on like goku using
kinton to
save himself from falling out of bounds
i mean to me that feels like cheating i
suppose the most significant thing to
come out of this match is that goku grew
his tail back but
even then goku doesn't knock it out out
of bounds or anything getting quits out
of fear
it's very unsatisfying the semi-finals
alright we've got four remaining
contestants vying for the first place
spot
goku krillin namu and jackie chun three
matches remain before we crown a winner
so
let's dive in krillin vs jackie chun
this first match of the semi-finals is
honestly a classic
dragon ball fight there's some iconic
toriyama paneling but trust me you've
seen nothing yet
this conflict also has a brilliant gag
which parodies those old kung fu films
you know those moments where two
warriors rush past each other we see
effectively nothing happen and then out
of seemingly nowhere
one of them falls after apparently being
attacked incredibly quick it's a famous
and somewhat cliche trick and toriyama
decides to deconstruct this concept
until all that's left is utter absurdity
as queen and roshi
i mean jackie chun utilized the same
attack resulting in krillin being downed
per the request of the ref they then
attempt to explain
everything that happened in
approximately 0.2 seconds
of action in excruciating detail
intentionally slowing the pace of the
fight down in hilarious fashion
everything from kicks punches spitting
booger flicking or even
rock paper scissors transpired during
that exchange apparently and it's a
great gag
the highlight of this fight for me
anyway has to be when krillin surprises
jackie and sends him flying out of the
ring
forcing him to use his secret weapon the
kamehameha to propel himself
back into the arena it's awesome after
that effort
krillin didn't have much left and in the
end jackie chun proved to be
too much for the young warrior
chun advances to the finals goku vs
namu's semi-final bout was
interesting for me for one main reason
it acted as a clear and effective way to
show what sort of powerhouse
goku really is taking techniques he'd
just seen moments prior
and utilizing them in battle with namu
made it look as though goku was barely
trying aside from krillin and roshi namu
would have been the strongest man to
participate within this tournament and
to see goku steamroll through him like
this created an
aura around his character i wasn't at
all expecting from the story going into
what should be
the biggest moment in his life needless
to say goku wins he advances to the
finals against
jackie chun in dominating fashion the
finals
this is and remains one of the best
fights the series has ever produced and
it's a crime that most people that have
seen dragon ball z
don't even know that this fight exists
contained within this one fight are what
will eventually become staples of the
franchise that to this day
are still being used there's an
interesting interview with toriyama's
editor torashima that
i think brings to light the reason why a
tournament setting
was ultimately chosen to act as the
backdrop for the climax to their
sophomore outing in this manga
nothing from fist of the north star
pointed towards a tournament arc
necessarily so
what was it well it was akira toriyama's
art style
according to toroshima tetsu ohara the
artist behind fist of the north star was
particularly great at illustrating still
or static images
and so toroshima wondered if hada had to
keep this in mind when drawing his manga
playing to his strengths resulting in
kinshira poking holes through his
opponents and
making them stagger to the right there's
not a lot of movement but it was
so cool according to toroshima and so
once he realized this he thought to
angle the coming arc
according to akira toriyama's greatest
illustrative talent
his ability to depict three-dimensional
movement
toriyama's level of spatial awareness
when it comes to these fights was what
drew me
as a reader and a fan into these stories
in the first place
and largely what set the series apart
from other actions shown of the time
keeping these aspects of akira
toriyama's talents in mind they needed a
place to easily demonstrate themselves
and what better place to show how
powerful and competent goku became
than on a flat three-dimensional stage
at the tenkaichi budokai
on this stage akira toriyama was free to
make full use of the space whether it be
through jumping flying lunging spinning
or
whatever his brain could conjure and
this fight between roshi and goku set
the standard for what many other manga
from that point onward
would try to emulate an aspect of this
fight that i think is easily overlooked
is
how so much of it is taken from roshi's
point of view from the internal dialogue
to the point of view and
narrative direction the narrative is
less saying can goku pull out the
victory here but
more so can roshi achieve what is best
for goku in defeating him in this
contest
on top of that remaining true to the
initial mission statement of the turtle
school and its philosophy
it really helps to build up and
establish goku as there's a mountain of
an adversary
early on in the bout which in turn helps
to build tension in the fight towards
its climax
forcing us to watch on as an audience
conflicted as roshi cycles through and
dives deep into his big bag of tricks
with goku
finding every answer to the techniques
the old herman had acquired over a very
very long career in mere seconds it's an
astounding fight and it's not done yet
due to the fight's length and
subsequently roshi's inability to put
goku away early
night falls over the arena and the moon
comes out forcing roshi to contend with
the impossibly difficult task
of great ape goku now destroying the
tournament grounds
and contend with him he most certainly
does in fittingly ridiculous dragon ball
fashion might i add
by using almost all of his energy to
blow up the moon
rip boss rabbit i guess ultimately this
leaves both roshi and goku almost
completely drained of energy with one
good attack left in each competitor and
the means with which
this fight ends is still to this day
genius in my mind
it's so simple it meant that there was a
winner declared but with
no one person having lost any standing
with us as an audience
ever the cunning strategist at the last
moment roshi notices an advantage he has
over goku one that no matter what the
young boy
couldn't possibly overcome his lack of
height and reach
for the very last time in this bout they
dash and move to attack each other and
this time
both fall after their respective blows
land but ultimately
roshi dealt the most damage thanks to
goku's lack of reach
leading to a graze instead of a sudden
connection on the turtle hermit
this fight was a brilliant use of every
single attribute that makes akira
toriyama's stories and battles
impressive and revisiting it for me was
a tremendous treat having not looked at
it in close to 10 years
returning to it with fresh eyes i am
happy to say that not only is it as good
as i remember
but it's better the focus this arc
places on the character of roshi is
stupendous
from his comedic value to his competency
as a martial artist to his generosity as
a human being
this arc was a true tour de force
proclaiming to the world
that dragon ball has arrived and let me
tell you
it was only just getting started
[Music]
let me see your war face